I want Total Immersion while I'm here in
Berlin so I've asked my good friend
Flula Borg to teach me German so that no
you don't want to dismiss my when I'm
enthusiastic I just it's like a shaking
of all the energies inside my head to
spread it sure no that was you saying
yes yes yes okay you just say yes yes
okay Flula is going to help me learn all
about Berlin the customs the people and
I thought it'd be nice if we also could
eat at the same time so let's just go
crazy and order some stuff I love it
yeah do you like hot encode do like both
of the temperatures the slaughter plate
this is just everything
yes a whole the whole kitty go to sleep
and it's just a bunch of animals were in
a bus and it blew up yeah we're getting
schnitzel as well yeah we need a we need
what is schnitzel exactly let us look at
it it's pounded for up there the nicest
be enough cross oh great ninja terrific
you will love it you will want to roll
around in it
one no look it is up to you that is so
much beer it's an exchange right yes
this one German beer which equals 45 Bud
Lights okay be very rude if I was like
broth that would be bad I would not
drink with your toes us into my
testicles so when do we stop looking at
each other without and these are a kiss
at some point we may smooch it it is an
option from Vietnam
Bruce pause here comes a slaughter
slaughter butter
keep looking don't feel it
sexually this town feels very
uninhibited like they love the sex
they're like how they love the freedom
of it not true why are we hiding it
dunno it's like if you are if you are
having a nice comic book collection
would you hide amazing spider-man number
eight now how you would put it on the
wall and show all of your neighbors okay
do you need to know some phrases I can
teach you some heavy phrases yeah teach
you some phrases if you like something's
very delicious you say is cut mission I
said sir it's like Swiss ice cream which
means I consider it the images I would
make a top of this food and then I would
place inside it to us when a shallot
Aslam shrunk team hosts world mean I
left us an instruction from which means
you probably do not have all of the cups
inside your cupboard incomplete cupboard
you teach meaning breaking song yeah
this one called one more will sit inside
you one more will fit inside you yeah
beer yeah
yeah I not kidding off on occasion oxide
kitna in a gift oxide ina get the pay I
indicate no time
I know picked up I know conversation
[Applause]
you